i want to show this this thread right
here goodness from aaron saberi
he is a gentleman inventor founder and
former ceo and he has his twitter thread
this is the one i was looking for he
says
sorry new york times i declined to be
interviewed the harassment of barry
weiss and scott alexander are only two
of the more recent reasons i no longer
trust your paper
helping elect donald trump is another i
encourage others in tech to boycott the
new york times
i don't know what he means by helping i
like donald trump but he received this
message saying
i'm a columnist at new york times i
found your experiments with gpt3
very interesting i'm writing you know
are you free to chat blah blah blah best
he then says the data makes it plain
that the new york times has abandoned
its commitment to non-partisan reporting
when the internet threatened their
business they made a devil's bargain to
amplify
outrage and us versus them psychology
racism wasn't a new problem in 2014
but their stock being down was take a
look at this
these graphs i wish you can
we can zoom in on that so so yeah it's
going to be hard enough to see for
everybody but i can explain it
the first little box says from 1970 to
2018
instances of the work it's word
frequency
sexism bounces around and then around
2010 it
skyrockets straight up misogyny straight
up sexist straight up patriarchy
mansplaining toxic masculinity male
privilege feminism women
women empowerment these words they're so
obvious
racism racist racists uh institutional
racism
systemic racism whiteness white
privilege
all of these words they hockey stick
around the exact same time
2010 when they made a devil's bargain
racism wasn't a new problem but their
stock being down was
talk about a zinger boom look at this
man and i've seen this stuff before
this is when the new york times realized
they weren't going to be able to compete
with the likes of buzzfeed vox the
huffington post
the hovington post was getting big
because people loved going in the
comments and yelling at each other
so all of these companies made a devil's
bargain we are gonna sell out
we're gonna make content specifically to
make you hate everyone else
and encourage you to fight each other in
the comments and just inflame tensions
because we want to extract as much as we
can from the system before it blows up
and just sit behind
and just watch youtube battle while we
make all the money
it reminds me of a kind of digital
fracking you know yep
it's the it's the housing bubble popping
in 2008 well this is the
the media bubble it's popping and it's
about to pop you
definitely it's been it's been tumbling
quite a bit like no matter what they do
they're being strained and it's
collapsing yeah
so what do they do because they've all
basically decided well let's just be
evil
hey why not let's be open about it too
they're they're not even holding back
they start running fake stories about
people like me
and they start going after other uh you
know pundits and personalities on
on social media their direct competition
and banning them
yes getting them banned yup who wrote to
uh someone wrote
was it cnn who wrote someone like you
should you should uh ban them because
they're our competition we talked about
it like a month ago
oh yeah the federalist yeah the fed they
didn't say because they're our
competition
right i know but come on yup
and it happened and uh i i believe to
this day
it could be wrong that you cannot google
search my youtube channel
oh really yeah so if you go to google it
they may
it may have changed it may have changed
it's the show it's our show now you can
probably find
yes and it probably helped you out yep
so for the longest time because of this
fake news
if you try to if you tried to youtube
search you to tim poole's youtube or tim
pool youtube
it will it won't show you my channel
yeah it's only irl
only you said you just checked it i just
checked it because this is a new
twitter yeah so what happened is fake
news
wrote fake things about me and it's
really funny because i worked for vice i
worked for abc news
uh within the span of three weeks vice
news wrote that i was an online lefty
and a right winger both yes yep
i have i've had i've had the today show
air
overt lies they made up entirely
wow the today show because we're the
competition for them
and they're desperate so what happens
youtube
also makes a deal with the devil seeing
the same problems
youtube gets scared that they're being
attacked by legacy media and tells
legacy media
will do whatever you say you know on
that note i'm just gonna take a
little tidbit of time to tell you to
share please share
our videos share our show first rule of
ireland send
send it into the into the airwaves
because we are not cnn
we don't have the power of google
helping us out check
go ahead check this out i want to show
you this uh aaron history twitter thread
he says
how does the new york times compete with
youtube identity equals virality
was the buzzfeed formula with articles
like x things
only a y would understand as recline
says outrage is deeply connected to
identity
the new york times is now functionally
buzzfeed with a cultured facade
he highlights ezra klein he says ezra
klein does a great job explaining what
happened
the internet means news has to compete
with more entertainment options
and no longer has to appeal to any
particular geographic region containing
people with diverse values
the the producers of politicized media
are themselves the most voracious
consumers of politicized media
the resulting distorted world view is uh
is what leads the new york times to
assure us trump had no chance in 2016.
what's happened what happened in 2016
with them saying trump was going to lose
is still happening to this day yep they
don't want to anger their audience
they don't want to say things like trump
is actually winning because their
audience will get mad and they won't
click the article
so they tell the audience whatever they
want to hear and you know how i know
this
i was told to do the same thing when i
worked for an abc news univision joint
venture
when they told me straight up quote side
with the audience
what does that mean i asked and they
said you know
you know side with the audience right
you know what what does the audience
expect
and so i asked the president of the
company are you saying that there
that if there is a fact-based news story
that could offend our audience we won't
report it and he said i think that's
fair
yes wow we were in a big meeting for the
presidential conventions
in 2016. and someone asked if this big
meeting of like 40 people
how are we playing this are we left are
we right center and
they said side with the audience that's
gross who's the audience
young progressives they said and i and
my response to this
you know i i kept telling these guys the
company lit all the money on fire when
it went up in flames
and i said your audience is not young
progressives
you are targeting young progressives who
make up a tiny percentage of the overall
marketplace well you know we talked
about it earlier
who's the the demographic that are
mostly online that the people that are
they are the younger generations so
they're they're tar they're trying to
target the people that are
active on the internet and anyone in
their 20s right now
is active on the internet always every
day they're constantly on their phones
scoping whatever
sharing that's the norm now but they
were not for the older generations
they were trying to make basically a
20-year plan thinking
if young people are progressive then we
want to make media for them so they will
age into it
and we will have a captured audience
once they move into their 30s
and become the powerful key demo it
didn't work
probably because for the same reason
donald trump won
they don't understand what's really
going on and they're all spinning around
in a toilet with each other
thinking they're getting reality but it
is a bubble
when bill barr was asked about systemic
racism
by the democrat he said actually a
police officer is more likely to be i
think 18
times more likely to be killed by you
know an individual on the street than a
black person is to be killed by a police
officer
it is 18 times something like that and
then their response was like
how could he think that he must be in a
bubble madeline dean i think grandma
said
he must be in a bubble and it's amazing
it's like have you considered
you're in a bubble someone's in a bubble
somehow disrespectful he was so
disrespectful
and that that pissed me that pissed me
off they're trying
they're trying to say like he's in the
bubble he was disrespectful
like that was literally all of you the
entire time
we're sitting in a bubble trying being
as
disrespectful as possible cut him off so
he couldn't actually
slam you with the truth if someone knew
this if there was any one person
who knew the stats as it pertains to
crime in this country i'd imagine
the the attorney general would be one of
the foremost experts
yeah like the good point running the doj
the fbi all of our what
could you imagine you know a republican
yelling at
a doctor like about vaccines being
you know causing autism or something
like just telling the doctor i know
better than you
i know you must be in a bubble and then
being like dude
listen i'm a doctor that's what they're
doing
the reason i use that specifically is
because
they constantly make that argument like
they are the people who are allowed to
defy the experts and no one else
yeah so when you have for instance
doctors stepping up talking about
certain medications and then they're
like ban all of those doctors don't let
them speak on the internet because we
are the experts i'm like i know it's
like wait are you doctors no no we don't
need to look at the information
but what do what do all of their silly
memes say why won't the right listen to
the doctors
i haven't seen those memes but it is i
tend to avoid memes
when it comes to masks and when it comes
to vaccines they all complain about how
the right won't listen to doctors yeah
and i'm like yeah there are a lot of
people that won't
they absolutely won't you know what i
defer to the experts i'll tell you what
when bill barr sitting there
as the expert gives you an answer you
don't say i'm right and you're wrong
these people live in a bubble listen i
want to show you this chart again and
explain to you
new york times word usage frequency i
feel bad for these people you know why
why they grew up being told that the new
york times was the gray lady the paper
of record oh yeah
and so they believe it they trust it
it's our good and honest journalism but
they're not getting it look at all this
insanity almost every single one of
these little boxes there's a hockey
stick
cultural appropriation microaggressions
you know bullied exploited
discrimination
and these democrats are reading all of
this believing it as law
they're in a bubble they're being lied
to definitely by a media organization
that is
dying and trying to extract as much as
possible before the ship collapses
yep then they go nailed it dude then
they can't understand
why the attorney general tells them you
were wrong
that the systemic racism problem you're
bringing up isn't real
and they say how could that be i read it
in new york times reclaiming my time
reclaiming my time before you're able to
speak any more truth at me
and that's why they wouldn't let them
speak i know because this is so obvious
these democrats are smart enough to get
elected
they're the grifters who know they're
manipulating the will
the ignorant who are walking like
lemmings off the cliff yeah
and so they're like well as long as
they're walking off the cliff and they
hand me one of the you know a couple
gold shillings before they jump off the
edge i'm happy
yeah and that's what it is the
republicans were more than happy to let
bill barr say whatever he wanted
mr bark can you answer the question go
for it because they knew
that bill barr was going to just lay it
out
and they had nothing to fear yep so
look man when you hear from these people
that
like what what this uh this this man
here arum is saying
that there's politicized media it is a
fact we are absolutely politicized
meeting
here at tim cast irl definitely i try my
best to make sure i'm following an
eclectic bunch
and i try my best to understand where
these natives are coming coming from
and i think it's fair to say that when
you have the right being the big tent
with former progressives former liberals
moderates centrists
conservatives and staunch conservatives
all agreeing the left is going off the
rails
we're also all agreeing the new york
times is pumping out fake news and then
we can see literal evidence they're
doing it
yeah i hate to say it but we're not on
the wrong side of this one
nope what's it i'll put i'll put it very
very bluntly
when you see someone respond to the
acting secretary of the dhs
you got smacked down thinking they won
this battle
when in reality the state has agreed to
deploy
state police officers to provide
security they're not abolishing the
police
they're emboldening the police they're
expanding the police
they lost but still think they won who
got smackdown
hmm yeah it wasn't the dhs
it was you guys so i'd be willing to be
peaceful protesters
oh yeah yeah if you missed that earlier
the peaceful protesters thrown them all
together no no it's an instant campfire
oh i'm sorry instant campfire instant
campfire instant warming method
yeah yeah yeah so i'll tell you what man
i don't know
what we can expect to happen come
november i'll say it 50 billion times
but based on the fact that all of these
media companies
are in the same bubble believing the
garbage coming out of the new york times
they they think they're going to win
they think they're going to win the same
thing happened
look at this so they don't have actually
you know what i think i have the other
tweet right here
around 2010 is when white people and
racism started skyrocketing at the new
york times
and you can see you know around you know
2014 and 15 it was very very high
hey that coincides the time that donald
trump was campaigning
they were convinced he was losing
because they have to keep telling
themselves we're winning that's a good
point they want to tell everybody how
dumb trump is
because trump is dumb gets clicks that's
true in reality
most people liked him and any news flash
he's not dumb he knows what he's doing
yeah
and he built an amazing the best economy
in 70 years you said
is that right something like something
like 70 or 80 years is ridiculous that's
crazy
until covered true but that's not his
fault
right and people still trust him more on
the economy than joe biden
so now you can look at this graph and
what do we see up to 2020 it's worse
than it's ever been
so why should i assume things got better
if the media still doesn't understand
why they were wrong in 2016. their
bubble is just getting smaller and
smaller and smaller
so the circle of the people that they
talk to is getting is
is no that is becoming more potent
i i have some bad news there oh goodness
subscriptions are growing for the new
york times
okay their revenue's up for america
american subscriptions
that's a good point or just internet
subscriptions general subscriptions
okay so that doesn't mean anything to me
but it also it's also fair to point out
too
they may just be capturing more of
the far left their subscriptions may be
growing because they're catering now to
people
who are socialists who want to read the
stuff that's in that little bubble that
they give
right so the new york times used to be
more centrist
right and now that they're moving
further and further left yeah their
subscribers are going up because they're
dragging some people with them
and absorbing some more but is there any
any graph that shows
that how many people they lost over the
past 15 years
you know people going what are they
talking about i'm not gonna follow these
people and my subscription
goes down and then sure it's now
starting to rise again
then that makes sense because they lost
a lot of people so now sure
they're they've got a little uptick i'll
tell you what man crazy lefties
you know i think there are a lot of
like disaffected liberals they don't
speak up and so they get ignored and
that could be one of trump's greatest
advantages
yep so i tweeted something once about
being a disaffected liberal
and it got retweeted by mike cernovich
okay and
he had he has a bunch of trump supporter
followers so as soon as he retweeted it
i started getting a bunch of replies
from trump supporters
some lefty then commented saying look at
all of the replies tim
look what you've become your followers
are all conservatives
i responded with actually it's because a
trump supporter retweeted me
yeah and then all of a sudden a whole
bunch of people responded that they were
liberals that have been following me for
years
they just don't tweet and i was like
boom there it is
nice a lot of the people who followed me
i have people who follow me since back
at occupy wall street
i get emails from people who are like
been following me since occupy i can't
believe what's happened to the left
a lot of the people during occupy wall
street were very libertarian very much
so
in favor of wikileaks were against the
you know
uh they they believe wealth and equality
is a big problem
they're not socialists they just think
that the working-class people
need you know we need a strong middle
class and a strong working class oh my
i'm finding a lot of uh similarities
with my beliefs right and they don't
like war
they want our troops brought back i'm a
libertarian i think that's that really
sums up my political
views the best is libertarian i find
something you know was really
fascinating that
there was i think was the american
conservative argued trump should have
fired bolton and hired tulsi gabbard
good point because she's
anti-intervention that's true
and they were like the true conservative
position is not to be in foreign wars
and if tulsi would would get trump to do
that then that's the right choice and it
would attract many
you know liberals who think that he's
bringing somebody on who's you know got
more liberal sensibilities yeah yeah
but i do find it fascinating that there
are a bunch of core issues that unite
conservatives and liberals under trump
because trump ran as a moderate
so you want our troops out of the middle
east you're not voting for biden
you get i i had a friend of mine message
me about
collateral murder where like it's just
middle eastern war stuff and so she's
super far left and i was like so you're
voting for trump
she's like no and i'm like are you gonna
vote for biden
yeah oh so you're supporting
intervention in war
i'm sorry man i get it you might not
like the guy you may have problems with
his policies
but if your issue is war the best bet
you have
right now in terms of actually some
policy that you you'd like is trump
and i'm not saying it's perfect not not
the least bit yeah but
joe biden nah so we'll i'm i'm i'm
looking at this stuff man
and i'm really wondering just how bad
the bubble is
but i'll tell you this go on youtube
and look up any political issue and it's
crazy how you'll see
what's popular and what isn't left-wing
content does not do as well as it used
to
nope now there is a button but there is
mainstream
that does way better right so so the
interesting thing is when it comes to
individuals who search and choose
it tends to be moderate to conservative
anti-establishment content
when it comes to the general default
liberal
they're going to watch nbc cnn msnbc
you know whatever and just get those
fake fake news comments
okay yep thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you